parabens were one of the first
ingredient classes that got demonized by
the natural and then the clean Beauty
movement this was sparked by a study
which found that parabens were in breast
cancer tissue there were a lot of issues
with this study they only looked at
breast cancer tissue they didn't compare
it with healthy tissues so parabens are
probably in those two and even if you
only found the parabens in the breast
cancer tissue it doesn't mean that
parabens are causing cancer it could be
that cancer tissue happens to collect
parabens more it could be something
completely unrelated because correlation
isn't causation on top of that in this
study the blank samples that didn't
actually have any tissue at all also had
parabens sometimes more than the tumors
so really all this study showed is that
parabens are used a lot including in the
detergents used to clean lab equipment
but this study got blown up it was
reported in newspapers in forwarded
emails on Facebook and so this idea that
parabens are bad and they're related to
breast cancer is just in everyone's
minds and it just keeps spreading